stunning comments from the U.S president
suggesting Russian threats to use
nuclear weapons in Ukraine have put the
world on the brink of Armageddon Joe
Biden's remarks were made behind closed
doors last night and serve as a dire
warning the Russia Ukraine war could
quickly trigger a much wider conflict
our Washington bureau chief Jackson
prosco joins us now Jackson what exactly
did Biden say
pharah the American president made it
clear he does not think Vladimir Putin
is joking with threats to use nuclear
biological or chemical weapons in
Ukraine because in Joe Biden's words
Russia's military is quote significantly
underperforming Biden told the crowd at
a private fundraiser in New York we have
not faced the prospect of Armageddon
since Kennedy in the Cuban Missile
Crisis the concern of course is that an
increasingly desperate Russia May deploy
a tactical nuclear weapon in Ukraine
something to counter the Staggering
losses Russian forces have faced Biden
told the crowd I don't think there is
any such thing as the ability to easily
use a tactical nuclear weapon and not
end up with Armageddon today the White
House is trying to calm concerns
suggesting there's no change in U.S
nuclear posture and no new intelligence
suggesting Russia is prepared to launch
a nuclear weapon still the concern is
that a corner of Vladimir Putin may act
in unpredictable ways in fact the
Washington Post reports that U.S
intelligence now believes Putin has
recently been confronted by someone in
his own Inner Circle in an apparent
disagreement over Putin's handling of
the war in Ukraine the criticism was
considered significant enough that it
was included in President Biden's daily
intelligence briefing pharah it all
suggests there's potentially significant
turmoil within the Kremlin and that only
bolsters those fears that Russia under
Putin May resort to unpredictable
actions